episodio 6
[Música]
venid es a otro episodio del podcast del
eje de tq en el cual hemos venido
platicando sobre diversidad sexual y
para este episodio la mayoría de los
hombres nacen con pene pero hay algunos
que han nacido con vulva los hombres
sexuales y la mayoría de las mujeres
tienen vulva pero algunas nacieron con
pene las mujeres transexuales y para
comenzar vamos a tener una conversación
con una mujer con texto
[Música]
o no
hola hola mi nombre es estrella mejía
soy chica transexual de 32 años de edad
radicado en la ciudad de iguala guerrero
méxico como comienzas a darte cuenta que
lo que estabas viendo un espejo de lo
que realmente tu crees mira lo que esto
comienza desde que naces creo que tengo
memoria esa razón eléctrica donde niños
y pues siempre me sentí como que niñas
nunca como que la confusión en mi mente
de que lo que yo lo que yo quería lo que
me traía haciendo mientras sean los dos
niños del jardín de niños y siempre mi
forma más más femenina
entonces pues mi vida fue creciendo y
creciendo pero mi familiar se dio cuenta
y nunca fue como obsesión de que termina
bien lo hace esto el otro a pesar de que
pues soy de familia de carpinteros
nombras sino obligó a trabajar como como
hombres pues creo que mi familia como
que también contribuye mucho a que no me
pudiera desplazar a pensar
de la familia nunca tuve ese problema de
identidad siempre supe lo que quería
solamente no es tener la información de
cómo comenzar en las clases y más allá
de tu familia comienza nada a tomar esto
pues mira creo que sea como siempre he
dicho yo no sé lo importante pues que
siempre ha sido la familia ya que te
apoye que respete a la familia y ya pues
los terceros pues viene sobrando lo que
es lo que su opinión sea creo que lo
importante de una persona gay transexual
bisexual lo que tú quieras siempre se va
saber a la sociedad si la familia está
en su la espalda y pues no no fue como
que también tienen les da la explicación
a las demás gentes se fue como que si te
parece bien si no pues también no estoy
como afrontar a la gente si la gente ve
que tu familia no te apoya pues más está
pic y piquet ipyc y piqué y te hace la
vida de cuadritos pero cuando las
personas pues nos vale ahora sí lo que
no se meta pues ya nos hayan y te toman
en cuenta para hacerte sentir más claro
cómo es que comienza este proceso
es una historia un poquito larga pero
fue por una decepción o sea yo estaba no
sabía la información de que una
transexual mente te está escuchando
entonces es una de las 107 años y entre
esa relación pues resulta que el chico
me dijo qué bueno yo siempre soy
femenina eso siempre yo traía el cabello
largo como hasta los hombros me parece
que yo trataba yo de ver más meninas sin
saber todo el proceso que existía
entonces el estudio comienza esa
relación con un chico que me dice que
entonces de verme más masculino para que
podamos salir a discos sumo a comer o
casi tanto como que de cambiar un
poquito
inconclusos a mí porque él sabe y todo
pasó pasó un año de la educación de
escondidas obvio y este y que me dice
que siempre enojo que no le dejaban nada
los chicos que usaban las chicas y pues
fue esa descripción que me llevó a mí a
buscar una a una chica estás muy
conocida aquí en mi ciudad y ella fue
como kg la emisión inicial de hormonas
tomara que
entonces yo comienzo de la transición y
la transición la viven igual todas las
chicas trans o varía dependiendo ciertas
características físicas yo digo que
prever que mira yo siempre tenga como
que mi familia muchas descripciones bien
no eran como que yo de andar así tenía
libertad pero no era como cantante
libertinaje cayó bajo la nota no vengan
o sea yo no tenía mucha información en
ese aspecto no entonces es así muchas
chicas por ejemplo a los 12 años ya
tiene amiguitos gate a sus amiguitas que
siempre una vez siento ahí se comienza a
la génesis 20 tomates tormo now tomates
empiezan a ver desde temprana edad en mi
caso pues no porque no tenía amistades
gays transexuales o no yo no sé yo
desconocía yo hasta esa ocasión yo
conocía este bueno ya la conocida en
periódicos eso porque era muy muy
conocido aquí en igualdad y la voy a
buscar y ya me dice ay no sabes que
santi flacas tomate su y ponte soy esto
y me da en el clandestino puedes decirlo
de hormonas y yo comienza con limón pero
eso que es tan importante que estuvo
ahora que las personas se acerquen con
un especialista
no hay ningún riesgo estos tíos al rezo
mina aunque efecto con una especialista
en el riesgo existe porque tu cuerpo
está absorbiendo hormonas que al final
al final se van al piñón entonces es
medicamento y que te va a dañar el
organismo en un largo tiempo pero pues
obvio que mejor con una especialista te
va a limitar a tomar las pastillas
adecuadas o indicaciones adecuadas para
que sea este es que te afecta totalmente
enfermedad las hormonas pues tienen que
ser de por vida porque pues la dejamos
de tomar y comenzamos con los rasgos
masculinos
y el vello facial la voz empieza otra
vez a rozar o sea es como retroceder
entonces si el momento es como que bueno
yo me en caso como que si me hecho
quedan hormonas y digo hay agua de
huesca son tiempo pero hoy al cabo de un
año dos años ya comienza estoy
regresando entonces bueno a comenzar con
las hormonas los cambios que tengan las
hormonas son únicamente los que
mencionaste o también empieza a ver el
crecimiento en otras áreas mira pues es
muy difícil que porque pues no sea como
biológicamente hombres pues no el cuerpo
no va a llevar la grasa lo que es que de
las piernas y pompano senos pero si te
empieza como que trabajar que el que el
busto que la cara que la piel hace
muchos muchos detallitos pues muchas
chicas pues si se desesperan realizarles
el ver no ver cambios y otros métodos
más peligrosos pero puede que no así que
estos son como las cirugías inyecciones
sin ser indie pues lo más son
escandalosos las buenas cirugías pero
pues también tienes un riesgo que tan
costoso es el tratamiento de las
hormonas mira pues éste en la mayoría va
a fondo va a buscar una clínica
inducidas que pagar en y no logo en
análisis clínicos y todo y te empiezan
un poquito con poquito muchas chicas
trans se desesperan y buscan rápido
entonces es cuando se automedican
que sale prácticamente económico pero
muy chicas abusan del medicamento y que
han hormonas hasta cuatro hormonas al
día o cuatro inyecciones al día existen
o están exagerando en la cantidad de
medicamentos pero si has de cuenta que
bueno en mi caso que tendrán como que
límite una caja de estrógenos me cuesta
250 trae 40 pastillas y es una pérdida
diaria o así yo me la tomo pues muchas y
tan se toma en 43 pastillas diarias pero
yo no yo me tomo una pastilla diaria y
debo terminar con una inyección que es
este que ya es una inyección y me cuesta
45 pesos esa la aplicó una cada ocho
días pero como debo repetir mucho si
acaso me den hasta diez a la semana
entonces como que cada quien a su
alcance ya su ritmo que podrías decirles
aconsejarle pues que el tomen todo con
precaución con límites y aunque quieras
cosas rápidas al ritmo necesario porque
pues de nada sirve que te pongas un 20
hormonas al día si al final de cuentas
el riñón te ese hecho lo que no le sirve
esa nación trabajar más a tu riñón de
nada sirve tiene una cara bonita si todo
el organismo por dentro tienes afectado
si entonces te tenemos sobre el límite a
límite de las hormonas o bien será lento
será lo que tú quieras pero va a ser
algo que te va a dar más más tiempo de
vida por es decirlo y todos modos es que
como te repito el cuerpo a saber lo que
necesita y lo de mano derecha y es ahí
cuando todas las líneas y el día de hoy
tienes ya conocimiento de alguna
institución fundación lugar donde se
pueda acercar la gente escucharlo en la
ciudad de mexico que existe que no me
parece el clínica condesa creo no no no
recuerdo bien pero pues aquí en mi
ciudad pues siente que todavía falta
mucho lograr poner la comunidad en donde
puedes trabajar una mujer trans
deberíamos tener
sectores a trabajar no pero pues la
sociedad siempre ha dejado nada más el
estilismo del sector servicio y esa
limitación que cada cada lugar o cada
sector pues a mí tiene sus sus
actividades para aceptarnos porque por
ejemplo aquí en aquí en iguala es una
chica trans tiene una estética me iba un
chico a hacerse un corte por muy buena
que sea la chica trans la gente pide
platicar que fue a otra cosa y no
cortarse el cabello pero los chicos se
limitan los chicos se limitan a ir a esa
estética para evitar los rumores los
chismes que la gente después
prácticamente pues nos dejan otra vez en
ceros el vaso show a trabajar un show de
invitación y te dicen es que ya tiene
sospechosos que tienes esto y en este
bello y no sé qué entonces creo que lo
el show de travesía y peso de imitación
se va más por el cual por los chicos tal
vez ese poder como te puedes decir
dibujar el rostro de un artista de sí es
como que no
la gente sigue más la transformación de
hombre a mujer y no de transexual
como que entra el tope que nos pone la
gente para dedicarnos de imitación
pues
tampoco pueden limitar
siempre al final de cuentas nos ponen un
tope el ciclo y pues la mayoría correa
el sexoservicio por ejemplo aquí en mi
terreno tienen cuadra guerrero muchas
chicas este han ido a la ciudad de
méxico a trabajar en estos servicios
llegando las torneadas dos cirugías
inyecciones este muy guapas mis
espectaculares pero pues si tienen nada
si regresan a su ciudad pues con nada
fue lo único que la que es la sociedad
les dejó o sea meses de servicio después
se ven con la necesidad de volver a
regresar y volver
a trabajar en lo mismo te digo ya que en
guerrero es cada violeta fox en lo mejor
las ha escuchado hablar de ella acá
porque ella éste entró al instituto del
seguro social común como chico y ya
dentro comenzó su transición a las
cirugías y todo y después ya no le
pudieron hacer nada porque estaba dentro
que si yo voy a libertad con operaciones
con hormonas con todo a lo largo y voy a
un institucional bien el trabajo no me
los dan porque porque ya está es
transformada sí entonces estamos con nc
esa oportunidad de estar adentro para
comenzar la transición pero muchas
chicas cannes comienzan desde los 13 14
años entonces no no no no los dejan otra
opción entre un conocimiento de las
leyes que nos protegen a todos como
comunidad pero existe alguna específica
que a ustedes como transexuales con esta
este cambio es transición que tienen las
proteja específicamente o los proteja
supuestamente existen leyes
se la pasan por el arco del triunfo
necio de méxico me parece que ya puedes
cambiar la entidad degeneren tu
credencial de elector en el toast
papeles el problema está en que es
nacional el cambio pero yo no te lo de
sanz válido aquí en guerrero pues si yo
voy y me cambió el nombre en necesidad
de méxico ya no ya me la hacen de todos
estando aquí en mi estado
por ejemplo las chicas que vivieron que
nacieron también instaladas en válido
hace todo el papeleo pero como dicen que
es otra delegación no sé qué tantos
pelos por dentro ya no tiene chiste
encaste el cansancio de méxico en
cambiarse el nombre para venir a la
rectoría no porque es otra delegación
cómo describes tú hoy tu persona cómo te
sientes o cómo puedes compartir nos que
ha sido todo este proceso para ti
pues mira efectivamente hay un proceso
pues
fue o ha sido lento pero mismo nunca ha
sido como que sería muy ahí
palabra muy fuerte si me explico o sea
yo comencé mi vida como chiquilla
siempre fui como que muy femenina
comencé con la hormona o conversa con
puedo hablar un poco poquito porque
poquito me cambien fue muy muy poco a
poquito o sea no hubo como que tampoco
necesita es decir mamá o papá pase
quiero ser mujer no vamos a ya cuando se
dieron cuenta ya ya sabe el proceso
ella estaba
como que ya que la brujita de mujer no
fue
el drástico ya fue poco a poco los
viejos
pero más allá del tema físico
personalmente cómo te sientes sientes
realizada sientes que todavía te hace
falta algo o es difícil esta parte de la
sociedad pues fíjate que
nosotros te repito o sea la sociedad
pues al final de cuentas pues sí es
importante pero creo que si tu familia
te acepta que quiere te valora y te
estás a gusto con ellas pues no tienen
por qué importante lo que tú opines ella
necesita sobre mi persona
siempre la manera logran papá y si digo
estamos apartándose
este ponerme esto aplicarme esto y si
tengo como que planes pero no es como
que lleva firme a ello
sí
no
primero no no no no no pasa nada me
siento bien
me gustaría pero no me obsesiono
es
importante para mí éste es albín con
familia
si viene una pareja sin un hombre pasa
delante sino también o sea no es algo
que yo no es lo melo forza que no tengan
que tener pero hay con su chica estrados
que critican inmigración hasta la cárcel
porque la pareja se va porque la vi es
cuando me limito a conocer una a un
hombre sabe como que me meto mucho esta
idea no es la mejor situación mía mete
ese idea es irnos a beber límite porque
te puedes meter en estos en esos
problemas
quizás justo a los a los chicos pero
pues siempre he metido mis límites a que
ver con las caras personas
me comentas al principio que un hombre
no se va a cortar el cabello a una
estética de una chica trans por miedo a
los rumores qué tan difícil ha sido
entablar una relación se termina
es muy difícil
además de que yo como te digo yo pongo
mis barreras vayan pero yo sube en unión
libre con un chico 8 años
y fue bueno en la fundación normal no sé
cómo una pareja rusa salíamos a comprar
salimos a cenar
simplemente la familia nunca lo aceptó
entonces la familia nunca aceptó y él le
dejan de cosas entonces él comenzó como
que a
quererse esconder de la gente para que
no fuera que dijeran a la familia y la
familia no lo dijera cosas a ver
entonces fue como que ahí el punto el
punto difícil difícil después al auto a
la vez yo digo bueno piensa vamos viendo
juntos o sea que le tiene que importar
la familia familia sabía que estábamos
juntos es su primera mente que lo
dejamos vivir sus vidas pero no usa le
metieron costa de metieron cosas hasta
que él comenzó a no querer seguir
conmigo viviendo en la misma casa
viviendo juntos entonces eso fue como
que lo que deterioró la anterior ola
reglas que no nos gusta y que ya no
hacíamos cosas de parejas a gramos está
más pareja pesen horas y de bajo bajo un
techo entonces cada que él suele tus
amigos con mis amigas
y pues eran como que
no éramos presionar en la casa
del agotó
rompió la educación y al final nos
separamos ya después de
ver dos o un año dos años comencé una
relación con un chico
durante el día
así fue una relación más libre porque su
familia aceptó la relación el chico me
llevó a su casa a aprender como su novia
su familia me me aceptó línea completa
sin colas por la familia con ser manos
con todo el mundo y más que todas van
muy bien si
hay veces que me conocieron cuenta no no
puedes decir no se dieron cuenta que yo
era tanto no porque con ese chico
estudiamos juntos en la primaria en
nuestra primera cita fue de un
reencuentro de ex compañeros de primaria
entonces ahí comenzó todo todo todo todo
no pongo empezamos como que a
a gustar y cómo salir y comenzó una
relación
la relación duró por cosillas
y ya de él
comenzamos como a salir en plan de
amigos
pero
después otros amigos con derechos
entonces él era él con él siempre fue
una relación a la que no le importó
nunca lo que la gente pintada y no fue
muy difícil para él salir hoy lo voy a
ofrecer es muy difícil porque por
ejemplo te ya no nos vemos el yo nos
vemos para nada no digamos nada del
mensaje pero hasta ahí y así será
complicado éste vuelve a tener relación
con una chica porque la gente lo vio
conmigo entonces la gente ya lo lo
señala de homosexual
yo siempre le dije sabes que cuando
comenzamos que
la gente te va a afectar o no nadie nos
asegura que no mostrar toda la vida
juntos te afecta ya a afectar el trabaja
entre inex y si no seas ha sido como que
no leo cullen porque saben que él me
vale pero si le ha hartado trabajo al
quien él conquista a una chica porque
las chicas aires que des hay porque son
visas con ella
si los tilos afecta con mucho a él
sí claro este es un punto que yo a ver
tú me dirás tú punto de vista
personalmente creo
si un hombre siente la fijación por una
mujer trans para mí continúa siendo un
alterne bears facial es un tema que la
sociedad reclama claridad si está una
plana de esos ojos si ese erróneo runner
ronroneo erróneo un hombre transexual
que le gusta transexual es porque es el
físico femenino
es una mujer de una mujer porque se
arregla con un objeto de zapatillas con
esto para él es una mujer él no cambia y
hay primeros chicos que me ha tocado
no te voy a decir que no tengo una vida
sexual cerrada no es así con sus chicos
y que yo me contactó con con chicos y
hay muchos chicos que él dicen sabes qué
positivo se cruza con que no estoy
no me afecta
eres mujer
porque no quiero ver esa parte todo es
respetable y todo
respetable aceptable sí creo que sí yo
siempre cuando una persona
llega a gustar a este adaptamos una cita
si se habla de sexo es que me a ver qué
es lo que quieres que lo que busca es
que lo que no pues es lado que usa para
saber a lo que vamos sí porque si me va
a dar como que
eres americano porque tienes ojos ya no
sabía hablar me viene claro es lo que
quieres creo que busca si se puede
adelante si no pues otro será no
es muy importante también desde ese
punto porque por ejemplo si ya de por sí
hemos luchado muchas chicas atrás que
quizás no fue mi caso lucharon para que
su familia de las acepte como que para
venir a decir que me da pena que no sea
no no no es así ya que enfrentamos lo
que lo que más miedo nos tiene que dar
que es el rechazo de la familia a los
demás sus valores obrando
sí y no sé
a mí no me importa que el vecino no me
quiera o clavecín a mí me burles casa no
me importa eso lo pongo en mi personal
ejemplo no sea cuando estoy en una cita
y que alguien me dice 'eres ha terminado
no eres terminado es como ni siquiera me
caja lo producto como porque me tendría
que parar a las prácticamente pero pues
a veces piense que si es necesario tocar
esos puntos porque si a mí me limitado
si me ha pasado decepciones sé que hay
no era lo que esperaba ja o sea y me
gusta
a ver mira
waltz y todo tengo parado el pecho
no tengo las caderas espectaculares como
es la imagen transexual que se está
manejando no buscas eso cuando no lo va
a hacer
y es como que siempre
las personas que van a estar la posición
a la que tú me quieres marcar o esto o
lo otro no tengo mis límites en mi casa
tengo con mi familia y las tengo que
respetar
una persona
es el punto donde a veces la chica
afectamos todos y acá estarán porque por
ejemplo
buscamos o aceptamos el que tengan
a ocultar
no podemos seguir porque la gente nos va
a ver después de las dos
vos sabes que muchas chicas que viven
solas hoy después de la una de la mañana
pero está tu casa y lo aceptan no nunca
si yo si yo yo no como yo le digo asia
si yo si tú como transexual luchas para
que la gente te tape fueras visible yo
porque van a esconder
pero bueno cada quien a veces sí como te
digo si existe como que dijo la pena
decir bueno ese chico pues me gusta
mucho no no me gustaría afectar lo que
la sociedad es la sociedad lo señale que
la sociedad los que un homosexual puede
estar como si yo y mi personal he
llegado a ser de esa forma no me gusta
mucho
aceptar eso esas este salida clandestina
específicos naciones pequeñas y existe
mucho el el rumor o si nos conocemos en
todos nos es una ciudad pequeña yo por
ejemplo me dedico al show de imitación
los lugares en los que me presento
mandan desde la publicidad por facebook
de esta noche se presenta estrella mejía
no pues la gente ya me tiene ubicada
quienes estaría mejía entonces como que
más difícil de los chicos como que
busquen como que más difícil busca una
relación con estrella porque es conocida
y voy a trabajar todo el mundo
poco atención de estrella y me van a
voltear a ver entonces si es como que
más complicado en mi caso más complicado
es este punto
pero pues creo que lo que no puedes es
de compensar con el tema que estás
también con tu familia no el tema es
cuando no tienen estabilidad familiar ni
les de habilidades emocional y ahí sí
creo que es cuando se siente es más
triste te pediría por favor entendidas
de las personas que te puedan escuchar
dejándonos como un mensaje a lo que yo
miré a mi mensaje pues al final sería
pues que luchen por sus sueños porque
pues mira el 31 entonces éste si tú
dices hay no no voy a comer a mi
transición porque quería la gente la
gente siempre va a hablar es en
transiciones en transición en este
tiempo te vas nada pues no hay que darle
gusto a la gente hay que vivir nuestras
vidas hay que hacer lo que queramos con
responsabilidad y sin tercero y mira
todo
personal
de la pandemia
estoy mi familia no me urge ponerme la
vacuna para viajar porque me encantaría
me encanta viajar
a
mi pronombre por ahora es y sigue siendo
de santiago
este este nombre viene por el nombre
real que mis padres me dieron pues es
sandra
pero
sólo yo lo decidí así no como santi este
tengo 28 años
y ahorita estoy viendo en el 18.000 con
santiago antonio porque lo de santiago
youtube una persona que me apoyó
muchísimo mi homosexualidad fue la
primera persona en realidad que lo supo
y mi hermano mi hermano mayor carlos a
él fue quien le comenté por primera vez
pues mi transición no sentirme a gusto
con mi cuerpo y en algún momento le di a
preguntar si yo fuera un hermano como te
gustaría que me llamara y dice sacó de
onda pues sí hizo su pregunta si a mí
fue bastante directa pues tú quisiera
ser un chico quisiera ser un hombre le
dije pues sí la verdad sigue contigo
nunca tenía un problema en compartir te
lo que siento entonces entre él y yo
platicamos sobre el nombre de santiago y
me dijo es que es l y aquí en la casa
todos acostumbra decirme muchos andy
entonces él me decía santi es como más
allegado al sandín entonces por eso fue
que decidimos el nombre de santiago es
algo que le pedí y antonio la diferencia
pues es que mi abuelo paterno siempre
siempre me decía antonio por el día así
por mí digamos por mi santo no y para mí
mi abuelo pues algo muy importante
entonces el nombre de santiago antonio
pues es es por eso por dos personas que
influyen mucho en mi transición y en
toda mi vida
cuando comienza o a qué edad comienza
todo esto existe un peso a los 6 años yo
recuerdo muy bien que a los seis años yo
yo
amaba jugar con mis primos con sus
carritos con todas esas cosas me llamó
mucho la atención vestirme con
pantalones y desde allí tuve ese
problema el no poder vestirme como una
chica como una niña no comportarme con
una niña pero obviamente pues era un
tema que no se tocaba y por javier
razones de la edad pues no no sabía qué
me pasaba alrededor de los 13 14 años
tuve un problema muy fuerte familiar se
me juntaron muchas cosas y ahí también
empecé a ver este este tema de mi cuerpo
justamente por los cambios que venían en
la adolescencia pues no no me voy al
espejo y realmente no me identificaba no
era nada fácil
decir mi nombre femenino porque pues mi
mente merece otras cosas a mi mente me
decía entonces que no eres una chica si
fue muy difícil y ver un espejo me hacía
llorar te lo juro de veces y si era
difícil muy muy difícil
conforme pasó el tiempo pues yo trataba
de asimilarlo pero me era difícil por la
gente por el qué dirán por por la
familia que también era bastante cerrada
incluso mis padres eran muy cerrados en
esa en esos temas
e incluso podría decir que ni siquiera
era un tema que se podía ver tan
fácilmente y a los que te diré 20 años
veo un amigo que también es un chico
trans él fue el que más me dio como el
el pie a decir sabes que pues si tú te
sientes un chico hazlo sale del closet
no como como decimos muchos porque él
sabía que uno no me sentía cómodo con mi
cuerpo con con mi nombre con la forma en
que la gente me trataba entonces ahí
viene el primer paso y si sigo hasta la
fecha teniendo todavía ese conflicto con
verme como con el cuerpo de una chica
pero pues creo que creo que todo esto
esta parte
influye mucho el apoyo de de la familia
y si pues si sigue siendo todavía un
poquito de problema en el verme
físicamente como una buena chica porque
él tus padres y tus amigos entonces nos
comentas que del principio fue un
rechazo o siempre te mostraron total
empatía no si fue un rechazo si hubo un
rechazo por parte de mi mamá cuando se
entera de que me gustan las mujeres sí
fue muy difícil era un tema que ya no
tocaba yo intentaba hablarlo y no me
cambiaban los temas me pregunta otras
cosas si hubo un rechazo por parte de
ella al principio que fue alrededor de
mis 15 años y uno de mis hermanos
también tuvo muchísimo rechazo hasta la
fecha con él no tocó el tema por lo
mismo pero mi hermano mayor si él sí me
apoyo mucho desde el principio el
primero en saberlo y el medio nunca va a
olvidar sus palabras siempre me dijo
eres mi hermana yo te amo como eres te
voy a apoyar y él pues hablo mucho con
mi mamá sobre no dejarme solo en esto en
apoyarme porque el final
nosotros quienes estamos juntos y no la
gente no no qué dirán porque creo que
ese es un punto que a los papás les
importa mucho el qué dirán los demás qué
dirán la familia qué dirán los amigos
los vecinos y si hubo mucho rechazo por
parte de mi papá pues con él no crecí
con el vivir lejos pero también tuvo
tuve un rechazo del tiempo después sí sí
lo acepto me dijo que me apoyaba y hasta
hace unos que tenía unos diez años
cuando cumplí como 18 19 años pues ya lo
hablé más a fondo con mi mamá y le pedí
todo su apoyo si le costó mucho trabajo
si ha sido una parte muy difícil para
ella sin embargo después de esa plática
que tuvimos después de incluso mostrarle
películas ha buscado la forma de
apoyarme y de estar más cerca en sí y
ahorita te puedo decir que me apoya al
cien por ciento ahorita con la
transición incluso yo le ha platicado
si ha sido como pedir un poquito difícil
poder decirlo bien más quiero cambiar mi
nombre porque en algún momento me hizo
el comentario después es que cuando tú
naciste me dijeron que eras niña y ya no
también no no te pases ya te apoye con
aunque te gusten las mujeres pero pues
dame chance pero a pesar de eso ahorita
sí sin apoya muchísimo si platicamos
abiertamente del tema sabe muy bien que
estoy en el trámite de de mi cambio de
nombre incluso hace poquitos meses me
compré mi primer vender y ella estuvo
muy emocionada conmigo e incluso pues
fue la primera persona la que le dijo
lleva más como me veo como es como me
ves tú como me proyecto y me dijo te ves
muy bien siéntete seguro de ti
pues no no permitas que nadie te diga
que no te ves como un chico porque eso
eres entonces sí ahorita ya es un gran
apoyo de parte de mi mamá y de mi
hermano mis amigos también este proceso
lo vivieron solos o acudiste algún tipo
de centro al que estén los especialistas
que pudieran ir sensibilizando
explicando el art moma no lo vivimos
solos lo vivimos muy solos cuando yo
tenía 14 años visita un psicólogo
justamente por estos cambios pero la
sesión fue como de un año y de ahí
dejamos de de ir hasta ahorita pues no
no hemos podido este pues acudir con
alguna especialista en realidad no no
conozco instituciones todavía lo único
que he hecho al menos yo lo personal ha
sido inclinarme mucho con mi amigo kevin
es el que me ha ayudado en esta parte el
si podría darnos como más información
sobre instituciones que se han visitado
mucho cómo comienza la transición en un
hombre transexual le inicié de entrada
por una pareja por una novia que tuve
hace como cuatro años cinco años ella
sabía ella de este tema
a grandes rasgos ella investigo ella por
la que me puso al tanto también de que
podía hacer pero en primera instancia
fue el decirme para mí eres un chico te
voy a tratar cómo está ella me hablaba
de antonio siempre me me dijo antonio
ella fue la primera en darme pie a toda
esta transición de ahí pues viene mi
primer cambio físico que fue el poder
cortarme el cabello para mí te soy muy
honesto fue muy difícil porque la gente
hasta en eso te señala no el cómo te
vistes el como terrell y tienen cambios
recortando el poco a poco el cabello y
ahí empezó a esta transición me gustó
cómo me veía me sentía un poquito más
varonil y sobre todo que ella en ese
momento me apoyaba mucho era de decirme
te ves muy guapo te ves muy lindo y al
principio si te puedo decir que había
una parte de negación mía no pero pues
así fui creciendo después empecé a
cambiar mi forma de vestir a eso le
atribuyo mucho mi mamá porque íbamos a
las plazas comerciales a comprar ropa
ahí y de pronto era mamá es que quiero
un pantalón así pero la gente me ve y me
decía pues ni modo o sea que te vean
pues es el pantalón que quiere aunque
sea el niño pues comparte lo vive muy
bien y me da un apoyo en esa parte y de
hecho yo era como más de que va a decir
la gente que mi mamá en ese momento mi
mamá era de apoyarme en esa camiseta de
hecho mi mamá te puedes ir conoce todos
mis gustos en cuestión de ropa
y ahí también empezó ese cambio en el
cambio de nombre pues viene por lo que
comentaba con mi hermano lo platicamos
mi hermano me dijo si adelante hazlo
si es es difícil es decir para uno mismo
aceptarlo es difícil
y expresar lo sobre todo pero han sido
cambios que de un poquito un poquito me
han hecho muy feliz me han hecho crecer
y pues ahorita soy el chico que soy
gracias al apoyo de mi mamá de de mi ex
novia en ese momento y de mi hermana
y cuáles son las hormonas que un hombre
transexual debe tomar este estos theron
y yo todavía no inicio que tuvo algunos
problemas del corazón entonces el médico
me recomendaba que por el momento no la
podía llevar a cabo justamente para
evitar algún problema más grave de salud
pero sí también y de hecho si me
gustaría me encantaría mucho poder
avanzar con este problema del corazón
que tengo para poder llevarlo a cabo
porque si es muy importante para mí
realmente ver esos cambios completamente
físicos y no nada más quedarme en esto
mi sueño más grande es ese ese incluso
dijeron te lo puedo compartir así todos
me dicen no no sueñas con traer un carro
o una casa o pero mi sueño ahorita mucho
más grande es convertirme en un hombre y
un nombre no quiere decir nada más y se
va a escuchar muy feo pero tener
solamente el aparato reproductor y ya
realmente para mí un hombre es sentirte
bien contigo sentir que puedes apoyar a
los demás sobre todo a las chicas sobre
todo a las mujeres he tenido mis errores
como ser humano pero considero que he
tratado muy bien a las mujeres con las
que he salido con amigas con ex novias y
ahorita es llevo muy a cabo es mi sueño
es verme físicamente totalmente un chico
verme como un hombre como lo que
realmente me siento y que me gustaría
más adelante tomarla la testosterona
pero si ahorita esto lo tengo pausado si
quisiera recalcar qué es esto de la edad
por ejemplo yo yo en algún momento tuve
un problema emocional porque me me
comentaban mucho y amigos ya sabes
negativos comercian esto ya tienes 28
como vas a tomar testosterona o sea ya
ya estás grande para eso si hubieras
hecho a los 20 a los 18 pero estás de
acuerdo que no hay como una edad para un
proceso como éste que es la transición y
sí me gustaría compartirle a todas las
personas que nos están escuchando que no
hay edad en realidad no hay un límite de
edad que te diga ya no puedes hacer esto
ya no puedes hacer el otro siempre se
puede mi sueño es lograrlo y ojalá más
adelante podamos volver a tener este
contacto y poder compartirles y decirles
ya ya estoy en este proceso ya estoy
tomando testosterona y estoy logrando mi
sueño me encantaría mucho que se pudiera
hacer para que más personas de verdad no
se trunquen por la edad ni porque sean
más pequeños o porque sean más grande yo
tengo entendido que antes era muy
difícil hacer este cambio de nombre como
si de hecho en el actual trabajo en el
que me encuentro tuve más un poquito más
de información justo porque es en el
primer ambiente laboral en donde a mí me
dan paz me abren las puertas cuando yo
con una compañera que era de recursos
humanos le platico mi tema y le digo
sabes que no me gusta que me hablen así
yo soy de santiago ahí es donde todos me
apodan santi me dicen santi y me cuenta
que si efectivamente hay una ley para
poder pues nosotros de alguna forma
defendernos ante la discriminación
laboral que en muchos casos todavía se
ve desgraciadamente he conocido otras
personas que me han dicho es que mi
trabajo nos afectan homosexuales o donde
se enteren que soy gay o donde se entere
que soy lesbiana este no no se va a
permitir no entonces en el trabajo
obtuve un poquito de esa información me
directora general el dueño de la empresa
este también me comentaron aquí no hay
esa discriminación no porque la ley nos
obligue sino porque por por ser humano y
por empatía lo aceptamos no tenemos
ningún problema al contrario mientras tu
trabajo sea el 100 no hay ningún
problema pero si me recalcaban mucho
esto de ya está penado ya nosotros no te
pueden en ningún lado en ningún trabajo
decir no porque eres gay porque al final
de cuentas pues sigue siendo una persona
vamos a ser homosexual o ser transexual
no quiere decir que tengamos menos
capacidades o que seamos
delincuentes o algo por el estilo en lo
que sí a lo mejor podríamos tener
conflicto no pero creo que sí es muy es
muy importante dejar claro que si si nos
pueden amparar las leyes que pudieras
compartir a las personas que están
escuchando y que comienzan con proceso
de transición o apenas están
identificando qué mensaje tú te gustaría
darles no como un consejo pues tenían
muchísimo los consejos que les podría
dar pero principalmente es
ámense a sí mismos mírense al espejo y
no vean realmente el cuerpo sino vean su
espíritu su alma sus ganas de crecer
como persona como ser humano y lejos de
tener el cambio porque pues por ejemplo
yo lo veo conmigo el no poder seguir la
transición con la testosterona si es un
punto que me pone a veces estrés me
llego a deprimir pero pues en realidad
no está tanto en lo físico no sino como
tú te sientas mentalmente como tú te
sientas espiritualmente por tu ser
déjate llevar por eso y más adelante se
pueden lograr los cambios no importa qué
tiempo te lleve lo importante es que lo
hagas lo importante es que luches por
ello que cada paso es importante así sea
mínimo como yo lo hice realmente te da
mucha satisfacción él simplemente
portarte el cabello o el ponerte una
camisa o el ponerte alguna loción créeme
es muy importante cada pasito vale la
pena y de verdad no no no los trunquen
así lleve en 5 años 10 años de verdad
llevarlo a cabo porque es una gran
satisfacción siempre he dicho si vas a
morir que valga la pena
has vivido no te quedes con las ganas de
nada y ese es un punto muy muy grande en
realidad ese es el punto no poder
compartir algo de lo que uno vive a
veces la familia no te apoya al 100%
pero créeme que ese ese 1 o 2 por ciento
que te den el mínimo que respeten tu
orientación que respeten tu espacio
habla mucho dice mucho y hay que
valorarlo también porque no es fácil
también para ellos como papás pues que
de repente un día llegue si les digas
pues me gusta esto cuando ellos tenían
la idea de que gustaría lo contrario o
no o incluso el decir pues sí yo sé que
cuando nací te dijeron para niña pero yo
me siento un chico y soy un chico creo
que hay que darles también un poquito de
espacio y tiempo a la familia para que
también lo asimile pero hay que ir
avanzando de poco a poquito tiene que
existir esa empatía como mencionas
hacían sus padres no finalmente ellos
crecieron con otras ideas tienen otra
educación simplemente con el punto en
que respeten aunque no lo logren
entender o apoyar es un gran avance
comparto esa opinión contigo muchísimas
gracias claro que sí me gustaría más
adelante poder compartir esa experiencia
agradecerte a ti por el espacio que me
está brindando espero que les sirva y si
gustan contactar y platicar más contigo
pues yo creo que lo vas a hacer pues
muchas gracias muchas gracias por
compartir te para mí es muy importante
casi no lo hablo pero tener un espacio
sí para poder compartirla es una
experiencia y en lo que he vivido con
esta por esta transición me da mucha
alegría saber que les interesa el tema
[Música]
para concluir este episodio quiero
compartirles dos cosas la primera es que
no podemos juzgar algo que no conocemos
algo que no vivimos creo que ayudaremos
mucho con el simple hecho de respetar lo
que otras personas nos comparten y de
esta forma quizás si no ayudamos mucho
aportamos mucho al menos no restamos o
no quitamos la oportunidad a alguien más
para poder vivir plenamente como quiera
como se identifique por último en la
plática fuimos con santiago o con
antonio mencionó una prenda que se llama
bean por si no lo sabes un vender o
pronunciando lo en inglés van der chest
van der es esta prenda que por lo
general vemos utilizan las mujeres sin
género para tener el soporte en los
cerdos en el caso de los hombres trans
lo utilizan obviamente para ocultar o
para tratar de hacer menos evidentemente
es pronunciada esta área y así alinearse
más
el cuerpo que desean tener
[Música]
déjenme saber sus comentarios preguntas
sugerencias a través de las redes
sociales que son instagram twitter y
facebook y ahora también en interest así
como en el canal de youtube todos los
encuentran como arrow el podcast el eje
de tq de cualquier forma voy a adicionar
un link en la descripción del episodio
para que puedan revisar todas y cada una
de ellas recuerden también que dar un
bonito like tan bonitos seguir un bonito
compartir suscribirse etcétera ayuda
mucho para que cada vez más personas
puedan escuchar toda la información y de
esta manera lograr esa sociedad empática
con la diversidad de la que tanto se
habla mi nombre es oscar olmos y nos
escuchamos en el próximo episodio para
continuar construyendo conocimiento
derribando prejuicios
[Aplausos]
[Música]